this video contains spoilers for
everything within the danganronpa
universe except for v3 if you haven't
played v3 than you're safe but be aware
that everything else is fair game enjoy
the video to make your dream a reality
you have to keep your gaze fixed on it
no matter what in this world if you lose
your focus even for a split second you
get left behind you have to keep on
swimming against the current without
even taking time to breathe that is the
kind of world my dream lives in hello
and welcome to danganronpa 101 series
the breaks down everyone and everything
in the danganronpa world and today we
are going to be casting our gaze upon
the ultimate pop sensation Sayaka my
zona Sayaka my zona is a delightfully
cheerful young lady who was rather
unfortunately caught up in the killing
school life game posted to hopes Peak
Academy
although Sayaka is far from your typical
smiley school girl and is in fact
exceptionally driven and committed to
her career as an idol
Sayaka initially chose to go down this
path due to being raised by single
father who had to spend exceptionally
long hours at work as a result Sayaka
took solace in a life Idol show on TV
gaining great strength and inspiration
from the girl she saw and thus became
determined to become an idol herself in
order to impart that strength onto
others unfortunately this decision would
not lead to a pure and simple outcome as
apparently Sayaka had to do many many
bad things and made a lot of sacrifices
to eventually achieve her dream of
becoming an idol exactly what these bad
things and sacrifices were currently
unknown for the most part but it is
heavily implied that the word bad may be
a bit of an understatement however to
her credit she did achieve her dream and
became the leader of an unnamed idol
group consisting of five members as his
standard without a culture SIA then
developed a rather large male following
but Sayaka in particular held a
universal appeal and became equally as
popular with female fans eventually the
group began touring and performing all
across Japan but it wouldn't be long
before they exploded to worldwide fame
which earned the attention of hopes Peak
Academy who went on to offer Sayaka a
place in the 78th class with the title
of the ultimate pop sensation
furthermore Sayaka unlike most students
in her class even had a history with a
fellow classmate being Makoto naegi as
they had gone to the same middle school
and who was accepted as the ultimate
lucky student although it should be
noted that while the two were aware of
each other they never actually had a
discussion with one another
rather time in middle school but Sayaka
was very intrigued by Makoto because she
had once seen him nurse an injured crane
back to health after it had become stuck
in the school for having been touched by
this act
Sayaka did feel the desire to want to
get to know Makoto better however that
desire was but one of the many
sacrifices she made in favour of
pursuing her career as an idol but that
would all change at home speak in psycho
would spend a year getting to know
Makoto as well as the rest of the 70th
class that is until the tragedy struck
the world in psychos class were entombed
within hopes Peak Academy for their own
safety as well as for the future of the
world and here after a further year
their memories would be wiped by the
ultimate despair Junko Enoshima and
Sokka would be forced to participate in
the killing school life killing game
would sayaka's memories of her time at
hopes be gone she was immediately drawn
to Makoto whom she still remembered from
middle school and while it seemed like
the two were on their way to developing
a strong bond
Sayaka would fall victim to the very
first of monochrome his motives designed
to inspire action during the killing
game this motive was known as killing
among loved ones whereby each student
was given a DVD showing people important
to each of them in sayaka's case being
her idol group and implying that they
were in imminent danger having been
greatly affected by this motive Sokka
immediately began devising a plan to
escape the killing game by plotting to
murder fellow student Leon quwata and
framing her middle school acquaintance
makoto for his death
ideally resulting in SIA cos victory
during the inevitable class trial and
you know all of this sounds wonderful in
theory but things didn't quite go to
plan and during her attempted murder of
Leon he turned the tables on Sokka
managing to stop her in the stomach and
leaving her to die in Makoto's bathroom
however with the last first-rank Sokka
managed to write Leon's name in blood
appearing as the number 1 1 0 3 7 and
following the class trial which found
Leon guilty of psychos murder
Kyoko Kyra Giri hypothesized that this
was psychos way of trying to make amends
to Makoto after attempting to frame him
for murder a theory that makoto would
take to heart as the number 1 1 0 3 7
would go on to be used as the password
for the abandoned hopes Peak Academy
building on Jabberwock island with
Makoto citing the reason for this
password being that it was the number
which a certain person had once left
behind in order to save him from trouble
some more fun facts about sock amazona
gone but not forgotten Sacco would make
an appearance in the anime series Donkin
room for three as a hallucination
conjured by Makoto along with the rest
of the deceased
70th class members and still not on
their psycho also appeared as an
illusion concert by Nagi took mida
during the super danganronpa 2.5 OVA
rather tragically it's implied
and Leon held a mutual attraction for
each other with Leon considering her to
be a pure-hearted girl and very much his
time the notion which Sayaka takes
attentive note of with a smile and a
blush on the flipside it can also be
theorized that this attraction is what
drove psychics target Leon in the first
place believing that he would be easier
to kill as a result the second idea is
something that has made much clearer in
the manga adaptation of trigger happy
havoc however it does need to be stated
that this is not canon and therefore
should not be taken as fact and one
stage younger sister of psycho was
planned to be included in ultra despair
goals similar to how many of the family
members of the other seventieth first
students had major roles in the game
however this idea was eventually
scrapped due to a being inconsistent
with psychos backstory as presented in
trigger happy havoc and finally a truly
useless fact about underwear during her
school years psychos undergarments of
choice wear pink panties accompanied by
a lacy bow but that pretty much does it
for Sayaka my zone if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support the channel and incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time and please do head over to
my disco server where a wide array of
shenanigan area takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured in the next danganronpa 101
[Music]
[Music]